you to be a good man I think it's more
their mother being like I'm gonna raise
you to show you how we treat and respect
women so it's an interesting
I haven't covered about that because I
kind of agree and disagree I
I
think I think only fathers can raise men
and I think only mothers can raise women
and I think a big part of that is
because
men and women have different take
different places in life
and I think I'll be honest I think I
don't
I don't know how a man can be the kind
of strong leader masculine man without a
figure that is that and the mother could
be that I guess but she usually isn't if
she's chosen a man
do you understand what I'm saying like I
I kind of struggle
because kind of like you said like the
elements that make the bad man or the
traits that make him dangerous are the
exact things that make him very
attractive
and if a woman is gonna essentially
raise a boy to not be those things that
could potentially be dangerous then by
default it means he probably won't be
attractive to many women
I feel I think that I think I think
there's a level of emotional awareness
that will work that will help but I
think fundamentally fundamentally I'm
not I don't know I agree with you
that's a lot of sense I think there's
like well there's a difference between
like masculine and feminine energies and
there's that balance and but then that
goes into why a lot of people aren't
supportive of same-sex couples adopting
because they're like
you know two men can't raise a woman is
that a valid concern well um oh
have you ever they definitely would have
read this you ever read the superior man
no
so even in homosexual relationships
there is still one who has a predominant
masculine call and one who have a more
feminine call which is why it works so
it has nothing really to do with gender
so in that sense
if
as long as you have a masculine feminine
yeah as long as you have that polarity
they can raise kids the same I think but
I didn't but then
I think it's
there are some things because gender
does play a part like a man like those
men will never know what it's like to be
a woman
so I think it would be harder for them
to raise a daughter I mean I think
there's like I'm
just saying I think there's genuine
concerns like that you could have I
understand I think there would like be a
valid point so here's my question would
you would you say it's more concerning
for a child to be raised in a homosexual
household or to be raised in a single
parent household
I mean definitely the homosexual of a
single parent for sure as in you think
that's better than that's better yeah
because at least there's like some
stupid like stability like I think it's
worse for kids when they see partners
coming in and out of parents lives so if
it's a single mom like they're gonna
have a bunch of like different guys in
and out yeah you know I think that's
kind of hard on a kid yeah I I can't
even imagine
so would you soon advocate for that then
for single parent households yeah
I mean I'm not I'm not saying like again
I'm not against adoption for gay couples
I'm just saying like there I don't think
it's crazy to say that that could be a
concern I understand why some people
it could be a concern do you think do
you think part of that concerns because
it's not really been done this is the
first time like anything for sure yeah
like you know we can't you know when
they want to go to the Moon I'm sure a
lot of people were concerned but that's
because it's never been done going into
space do you know what I mean yeah I
agree I see both sides yeah I could see
it
do you think race plays a part do you
think
oh this is this is if we're going
controversial do you think it's
what do you think about a white couple
adopting
an Asian baby
I don't care
they love the kid yeah I don't care do
you think it's do you think it'd be
better for that baby if they're with an
Asian
parents
or do you think it does make a
difference
um I mean they'll put you on the spot no
I'm saying I mean I'm sure like the only
difference I could see is potentially
like questions would probably get
annoying over time and people always
asking if that's your parents and you
know stuff like that yeah but overall I
mean if they love the kid because I
think this is this is a big reason why
at least from people I've talked to why
a lot of black women are
prefer
to settle down with another black man
because if it was anyone else especially
if it was a white man they're like they
will never understand and that
because they'll never understand they
wouldn't you know what I mean
I don't know I'm just
I'm just playing devil advocate to
everyone's opinions boy
I do love it what do you think
um well Paramount is obviously if that
car if that child needs care and is
being cared for that's Paramount but
then you've got the whole can you unjust
like
it's the whole difference between
sympathy and empathy we can sympathize
with racial struggles but you can't
empathize because you've never been with
it and obviously if someone being
adopted into a racial minority or their
own race they're going to get a more
accurate empathic experience
um but then
white families adopting racial
minorities those white families are
maybe potentially going to be able to
provide more because of the experience
provided to them in their white
privilege so it's really like oh it's
really messy like in an Ideal World I
would love for people to be adopted
within like their own existing Community
I just think of the birth parents are
fine with it and the if the birth
parents are fine with who they give the
kid to yeah and the like why stop them
yeah if the birth parents are cool with
it like what I stop at another
controversial question okay
what would it take for your child to do
for you to disown them
um sex don't say be left with don't say
be a liberal no no no no no no
um
no I wouldn't mind my sister is no just
yeah so
um I would say
to disown them
um any sexual act against the kid
yeah yeah you're dead to me I'll never
talk to you I think you should die if
you touch a kid that's why yeah death
penalty I stand on this do you believe
in the death penalty for people that
touch children yeah just in general
anything that's if you murder a kid
touch a kid yeah I believe that the
death penalty is
full effect like I wouldn't even no
questions okay yeah all right how about
you
um yeah and I agree with that point
um like I want like anything like rape
like sexual like murder you know what
I'm gonna be like because sometimes
people murder people in self-defense or
within good reason like there have been
murder cases where yeah someone will
murder someone because you've touched a
kid and I'd be like hmm I don't condone
it but I can understand it but I'd love
to categorically say my moral compass is
XYZ but if you're a parent you are
willing to overlook a lot of [ __ ] or
you're willing to be like
do you know what I still see the good in
there more XYZ so I wouldn't know but
yeah if they did any like rape I'd be
like I literally
if I was a parent I'd be like I did not
raise you this way so you've
disrespected me and you've hurt me and
therefore
go [ __ ] yourself yeah yeah anything
about a kid
um
like ah yeah those are the two that I'd
100 I I very like yeah like you've never
seen 100 but those are the two that I'd
be like no in doing that like you [ __ ]
me over and therefore I'm not gonna care
about you if you didn't care about me
like hello and
attack
s on a daily
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible